use language is it all these technically
not a day
the universe is kind of full day is 24
hours
but you don't do that you just
acknowledge that you can say you work
you was working for 3 days we we know
working 8 hours a day is counted as a
day in the working world right totally
different and so in the Jewish world the
same thing if you if any part of the day
is going to be counted as a full day
with that with that point being said
they only working I mean they only he
only he died
on at 3:00
>> Friday
still daytime and you won't count that
as a full day because the sun set yeah
you know the Jews did they said at the
time a day and a night are an Omer and a
part of an Omer is as if it is a
full Omer
what I'm going to do
what I'm going to
what I'm going to do I'm going to talk
to the rabbi
about this issue
cuz see I did research
Matthew Matthew Mark and John
all of them
came some 40 to 70 years after the fact
I I did my I did my research I know what
I'm talking about you just you just
you you think they came they wrote it 10
years 40 and 70 but that's not 40 years
after the death of Jesus
all right okay yeah cuz
the death of Jesus is 30 or 33 AD so
you're actually talking
even with that timeline we're talking
about 10 to uh I'm not saying this in
the class that I went the richest class
in the Catholic in the Catholic
and the nun is talking not me her she
explained this you're misremembering
because I'm not misremembering
in between the year 40 and 70 that
wouldn't be 40 and 70 I mean I remember
very well I remember very well cuz John
is the one that came late
John came John came late that's why she
used that that time frame for 40 to 70
years cuz John came late. That's fair.
Right, if you say she's including John
as potentially being written in the
'90s, then that would be potentially a
40 to 70-year time frame. So, what I do
is I listen to people as long as they're
making me some sense. Okay. If it's
making sense to me, I'll listen. Don't
mean I'm accepting it now, but I'm going
to listen to your logic. Okay?
I I hear you. I hear you. You're not
telling You're not giving me 24 hours.
How many
How are the biographies of Muhammad
reliable? Do you know what happened in
Muhammad's life? Okay. Okay, watch this.
Watch this.
Allah says in the Quran that he will
protect the Quran. I'm not finished.
I'm not finished.
I'm not finished. Wow.
No, no. No one has changed his words.
Number one. Now, number two. That's
right. Prophet Muhammad Prophet Muhammad
said that anybody that lies on me, he's
going to hell. Mhm. Right. Now, I
understand that the Hadith are not 100%.
And I understand that what we're reading
from uh
history is not 100%. Mhm. You see? But
the Quran is 100%. Wow. Wow. And And the
chapter 15
Think of the ayat. But
he says Allah says that I will protect
the Quran myself. Now, watch this.
>> Wait, brother. He doesn't say that.
He says he'll protect the reminder.
The dhikr. The dhikr. Dhikr. The dhikr.
Do Do you know what Do you know what
that's a reminder is? The dhikr means
reminder. Wait, that's a
Hold on. That's one Wait, wait. No, no.
I got one. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait.
The word dhikr
Quran is It's not It's not And no, I
don't need it. Oh, you don't need it.
You have to.
No, no. I But I know some You know some
Quran. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay. But
anyways, anyways
So, dhikr
nur
These are nicknames light
They're nicknames of in the Quran
because these are the qualities and the
attributes of the Quran. And you know
what else is called noor and a
thickener? Is what? The Torah and the
gospel. That's right. So if Allah
protects the vicar, the reminder, he
protects the Torah and the gospel. No,
no, no, no. What?
No, no.
We know that the Torah let's go with the
Torah. I'm trying to give you logic, OG.
The rab- the rabbis,
they in- they in- they in- they put
information in there from their
perspective along with the Torah. Wow.
>> Where the Quran say that? Wow, wow, wow,
wow. The Quran say that? This history
says that. Okay, so so the history is
going against the Quran.
>> Uh-huh. Cuz the Quran look cuz the Quran
says nobody can add to Allah's word. And
so watch this. No, the Quran says none
can add to Allah's word. You agree? No.
Yes, they are. No, so
for example, when it says that none of
nobody can change Allah's words.
>> Right, right, right. The Torah are
Allah's words, right? Yes. But he was
talking about the Quran straight. Yes,
he makes a general statement.
>> that's a general statement. Yeah. Cuz
history shows that the Torah has been
corrupted, the Zabur of the the Psalms
David has been corrupted, the Injil has
been corrupted. This is not first-hand
statements from Jesus. So let So let me
go with you. So says Bonner. No, not by
the way. Let me go with you with this,
all right. So you But can I Oh, gospel
Bonner. Yeah, yeah. Oh, wow.
So let me go with you with this, all
right.
Let's say they're corrupted.
Were they corrupted before Muhammad
became a prophet or after? Before. Okay.
So they're corrupted before Muhammad.
So then why is it I need you to help me
out. I got you.
Why is it that the Quran in multiple
places I'll give you one, chapter 2
verse 40.
It says that the Quran came confirming
the scriptures that's with it. Got you,
got you. Here you go, I got a Quran,
buddy.
He did this. He did He got it. You don't
trust my Quran? Uh-uh.
We got We got it FROM THE MALL.
I GOT IT ON MY I DOWNLOADED ON MY YOU
DON'T WANT THAT PHYSICAL COPY? I'm going
to give it to you this physical right
here. He likes his phone better. Man,
that's spiritual. You feel that, man. I
got you.
You got to feel it. I got you. Yeah. You
got to hold that Quran, man. No, I'm
going to tell you.
I'm going to tell you what the Quran
says about
that. Just answering your question.
Okay? So, you're about to tell me why
Allah's confirming the scriptures in
Muhammad's time? Don't answer my
question. I'm giving you this. I'm
giving you this. But that's that's
chapter chapter uh
three
chapter three logic I s- I uh Step down.
Step down. 115 uh 113, I think. Step up
to the Oh, oh, oh. Yeah. I'll talk to
him. Okay, right
But
that way. Yeah.
There you go. All right, where did you
Where are you going? I'm going to
chapter three
verse one. Say let me got them. You got
to listen to the to the director. Mhm.
There we go. That right. That right.
That right.
The guy came with his gang. Hey, he
pulled up.
>> Yeah, he pulled up, man. He pulled up,
Drake.
Loud something. Yeah, he
I'm like, "Damn."
Who fighting down here?
I made it.
Hey, better late than never, man. I
know.
I had to work. I had to do stuff
yesterday. Yeah, Drake here.
Heli
I don't I don't I don't buy it. So, how
is this verse going to going to help
with Something tell me
you lying.
Something tell me you lying.
I just don't know what you lying about.
So, forget us.
That's not going to answer my question.
It's going to ask the question in a
minute, man. I'm I'm going to get to
that. You sure? I'm trusting you, man.
No, we already told you. Okay.
Cuz if they were corrupted in Muhammad's
time, that would mean that Allah's
confirming corrupted books.
Which would mean Allah's making a
mistake.
>> No, he's not It doesn't mean that at
all. It means that human beings they had
control over it and they did stuff with
it with the So, then why would Allah
confirm corrupted books? Why would he
say corrupted books are true?
He's saying that the parts in that book
that is related to what was originally
285, no it isn't. It don't say that. It
doesn't say it's confirming part of what
they have. It says it's confirming it's
confirming. Yeah, yeah, what is with
them is what what was revealed and then
in that mixture in that mixture they got
other stuff in there, too. Where where's
So, if it's Say that. The Quran doesn't
say that. Quran doesn't
Okay.
Quran says in 285 that You have to
believe in all of the book, not parts of
it. And if we believe in parts of it we
go to hell. Yeah, fine.
That's another story.
>> No, even in this life we're supposed to
have disgrace.
>> And the Bible says no pork.
Okay.
First Corinthians
Smart man. chapter 11
5 through 7 and
the glory of And that's that 300 lbs
right there, man.
that she should cover her head and if
she's not going to cover her head she
should be bald.
It's in the
No, no, no, no, no, no. Hair covered all
of it. Stay focused. I'm very focused.
I'm trying to I'm trying to figure out
why Allah is confirming books that are
corrupted. Okay.
He's confirming the truth that existed
in the book. It doesn't say that. It
says it's confirming what is with them.
So, that's why you go that's why you
want to read the Arabic.
Right.
You want to say something? Oh, he just
did the the machine gun.
Okay. He just did the machine gun there.
He says
He says lay su suh lay su suh wah
Yeah.
I wanted to say something. He didn't
make it across the street.
So, I thought you wanted to say Want to
turn the brightness up?
Hey, you you don't be touching his
phone.
You know what you did.
You're supposed to be able to just swipe
down.
>> this. I got this. Hold on. What verse is
that, though? That's the first 113.
313? 113. 113.
There we go. Come on, huh? There we go.
Come on.
That's right.
Right. Finally. Yeah.
>> you so long to bring IT OUT THE BOOK,
MAN? I wanted cuz I got it here.
Oh, you got it in here?
I got it I got the I actually
was in your office.
3113 That ain't going to help. No, none
of it helps. It's going to help It's
going to help a whole lot. I don't know.
If you go to 3114
The Quran helps us a lot, man. It
defends our book. Hey, Drake.
It defends our book against the movement
on all of the tablets.
I would have thought the signs would
have been in English or something.
Here we go. We got them.
I'm sorry, y'all. I got to eat. My thing
is Why don't you have it in English?
He says hold
3 what? It says It says "Lace who so
where
Lace who so where I'm in a little
guitar. All the people of the book are
not the same.
Who my twin call E my twin
yet to Luna
yet to Luna.
They recite the signs of Allah Akbar.
And and they
yes you do and they make prostration
prostration at night. He's come up those
who they hold on to the perfection of as
they know it.
He's talking about those people that
have not corrupted the text
Beautiful. Here's the deal. That's
really good.
10 Commandments
It says No, no. It says It says that
whoever
says they are prophet they prove they
are false a false prophet slay them. So
What 10 Commandments? What what what
what are you reading?
>> Where are you getting that from? It's in
10 Commandments. Read it. No, it's not.
It's in 10 Commandments. It's not in the
10 Commandments.
It's but but it is one of the It's in
Deuteronomy. It's not in the
Anyways, anyways it's supposed to be in
the Bible.
It is It is in the Bible.
>> Okay, now.
The point is is that
Jesus the the in the Torah in the 10
Commandments, God taught one God.
Worship Worship me as one. Put no other
god before me. And all that business.
This isn't helping what I asked.
>> Yeah, wait wait wait. Let me get a
point. I You're making a point that's
not touching on what I said.
>> a point. Okay.
So,
if Jesus was talking about three in one,
that's totally contradictory to the
Torah. All right, let's go with this.
So, let's say that three in one is
contradictory to the Torah. What you
brought us demonstrated that there's
genuine people of the book who have
preserved scripture, right? They didn't
corrupt it. They got some They got They
didn't have some of it. Very good. So,
they have the preserved scripture. Have
some. No, it doesn't say some. This This
is what I'm saying. It's the Quran is
confirming what is with them. If what is
That means what is with them is
preserved scripture.
>> not He's not confirming all of it. He's
got He's not
>> the Quran say he's only confirming
parts? If you show me that, I'm good.
He's confirming what that what lasted
through the transition. No, that's not
what it says. Look, notice how I am
quoting the Quran what it says. You got
to add to it, brother?
>> I got to add to it? Okay.
>> you the details of the verse we're
talking about. Right. So, I'm Look, I'm
I'm quoting the verse
verbatim. It says, "Believe in what we
have sent down." I'm talking about the
Quran. Yeah, yeah, yeah. "Confirming
that which is already with you." Right.
So, that means what is already with them
is true. Okay. So, in in the time in the
time of Muhammad when he was living, he
was teaching the Jews because they knew
the the confirmation of a prophet to
come like him. Ah, there we go.
>> Moses said Moses said
>> pause there. I I don't mean to cut you
off, but this is a good point. So,
basically, the Jews are supposed to be
able to recognize Muhammad based on the
Torah.
Exactly. And then I'm I'm going to say
if that's the case, then this is our
problem.
Our problem is is that when we compare
that, we see that he's not in line.
Okay. Now, if you have examples where
you think he is, I'm willing to talk
about It says It says It says
Deuteronomy I quote Deuteronomy
Deuteronomy 18:18. Yeah, yeah. It says,
"I will send to you a prophet amongst
your brothers. like unto you." Why don't
you read the first verse 15? Because I
don't know the Bible like you.
I will raise up a prophet like me from
among you, your brothers.
The brothers to the Jews and the Arabs.
No, the brothers are you got Isaac and
you got Ishmael. No, read verse 15. I
will raise up a prophet like me from
you, from your brothers. Because in
Deuteronomy
No, no, no, I'll read it No, no, you
didn't say that. It's not written there.
Deuteronomy 18:15. Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I'll read it for you right now.
You want to pull it up for your showing
as well.
>> What what version are you reading from?
Any version it's in there, man. Can can
your brothers be fellow Arabs or fellow
Jews?
Can they can they be considered your
brothers as well?
No, no, no. Answer I'm asking a
question. All hu- all humans that that
are Muslim first and foremost, they are
brothers from all over the world. No, we
Well, you're trying to go to go
somewhere else. According to Deuteronomy
18, you're saying it's going to be from
amongst their brothers. Okay, in that in
that context Can Can Can Can your own
fellow Arabs or Jews be known as your
brothers? Look, here are all the verses
here. So, the Lord will raise up for you
a prophet like me from among you, from
your brothers. The Lord will raise up
for a prophet like me from a
Like me, yeah, I'm saying that. But
that's the same in Deuteronomy. The
phrase brothers
It refers to
In Deuteronomy, the phrase brothers
refers to Israelites every time. No, it
doesn't. 7:15 No,
it does not. Deuteronomy
Deuteronomy 3:20 Over and over again.
That's what that means. So, when it says
So, when it from among your brothers So,
when it says I will raise up a prophet
like me from among you, your brothers,
that literally means Israelites. Okay,
like like me, fine. Yeah, Israelites.
>> Who Who is like him? Jesus. Jesus like
him?
>> Yes. Okay, so
Moses had
community. He had a law He had laws.
Yeah, Jesus had laws. Jesus didn't have
He didn't have it. He did. Okay, what he
came to do John the Torah and the angel
of the Torah and the angel
wait wait wait wait wait
no he
the spirit of the law back into the law
Jesus came abrogating something of the
Torah that John
2 and 3
you too far according to
Jesus came
to Texas
chapter
3 it says
I have come confirmed with the sign from
the Lord and I come confirming the Torah
which is confirming and to make lawful
some of that which has been forbidden
but so the Torah had outlawed things
Jesus came and made the ones who did the
outlawing with the Jews
no no no no no no no no no no no no they
they they corrupted that's the that's
the corruption part the part they that's
the corruption
that's the corruption I
really got to go
and cash this check and go pay this bill
you know but I just wanted to you know
but
hey hey what's your name man Shams Uddin
Shams Uddin Abdul Rashid Shams Uddin
Abdul Rashid
son of the faith that's right and when I
was your age
I used to be like this
what
what you used to be like
putting on the board
you used to be putting on the board
what you doing I was a coach of a
basketball team and
I said man you 62 they told me to
you can't you can't dunk it he said you
can't dunk what you talking about I said
give me the ball boom boom bam now like
I said
you know
and I wish I had time to go through this
and sit down
he probably can't dunk anymore, but he
can shoot right here. can He coming He
coming
HE COMING TO THE FOUL line like Bank
shot off glass.
It's God.